en el vídeo anterior vimos la
condensación alcohólica simple es decir
usando la misma molécula en este vídeo
veremos la condensación alcohólica mixta
o cruzada en donde ya no tenemos dos
aldehídos iguales
esta vez son diferentes del lado
izquierdo
tenemos benzal de ido y del lado derecho
pro panal necesitamos averiguar qué tipo
de añón en o lado vamos a formar si
agregamos hidróxido de sodio como base
cuál sería nuestra unión en ola pto
bueno primero necesitamos identificar
nuestros carbonos alfa empecemos con el
pro panal
sabemos que el carbono alfa es aquel que
se encuentra junto al carbón y lo así
que este es un carbono alfa y tenemos
dos protones alfa en este carbono
recuerden que este hidrógeno del
aldehído no forma parte en el mecanismo
no necesitamos preocuparnos por esta
parte ahora analicemos el ben's aldehído
si pensamos en este carbono que está
junto al carbón y lo este carbono ya
tiene cuatro enlaces el ben's aldehído
no tiene un protón alfa entonces podemos
decir que el año en ola pto se formará
en el pro panal déjenme redibujar esto
para que sea más fácil
aquí tenemos nuestro anillo
el carbón y lo no pondré este hidrógeno
porque nos estorbaría en el mecanismo de
este lado dibujaré el pro panal de una
manera diferente
me gusta poner este carbono hacia abajo
así será más fácil muy bien ahora
pensemos en la des protón acción el
hidróxido de sodio tomará un protón alfa
y dejará los electrones en el carbono
alfa así que en este carbono tenemos una
carga formal negativa este es nuestro
año en o lado núcleo físico me gusta más
usar la estructura del carbón porque con
el carbón es más fácil hacer el
mecanismo rápidamente ahora que ya
tenemos el núcleo filo nuestro núcleo
filo atacará a la porción electro física
del vents aldehído recordemos que el
oxígeno es parcialmente negativo y este
carbono es parcialmente positivo
esta es la porción electro física
que este par de electrones libres
atacara a este carbono empujando estos
electrones hacia el oxígeno dibujemos el
intermediario formaremos un oxígeno con
tres pares de electrones libres y una
carga formal negativa pero lo más
importante es la formación de un enlace
carbono carbón justo aquí y luego
tenemos el aldehído
y este carbono
estos electrones en rosa formaron este
enlace y tendríamos un alcohol sido como
intermediario pero como solo queremos
llegar al producto final y no nos
preocupa tanto el mecanismo de una vez
proponemos el alcohol sido para formar
nuestro haldol así que en el siguiente
paso cuando calentamos formaremos un
producto conjugado aquí junto al carbón
y lo tenemos a nuestro carbono alfa y
aún tenemos un protón alfa pensemos en
el hidróxido que funcionará como base
tomará este protón dejando estos
electrones que empujarán a estos
electrones dibujemos el producto
aquí tenemos nuestro anillo
y hemos formado un doble enlace justo
aquí también tenemos este carbono hacia
abajo y nuestro aldehído hemos formado
un en 'la como nuestro producto sigamos
a los electrones
estos electrones en azul se movieron
para formar el doble enlace y ya
teníamos este enlace rosa carbono
carbono este es nuestro producto es un
producto conjugado el objetivo fue
dibujar el producto a partir de estos
reactivos identificar el carbono alfa y
pensar en él no la toque se forma veamos
otro nuevamente tenemos diferentes
posibilidades de carbonos alfa primero
analicemos la ciclohexano sabemos que
este puede ser un carbono alfa oeste y
en este compuesto tenemos dos grupos
carbon hilo este puede ser un carbono
alfa
ahora a cuál de todos estos carbonos
alfa vamos a desproteger cuando
agreguemos nuestro stock sido de sodio
como base bueno en uno de los vídeos
anteriores dijimos que cuando un carbono
alfa se encuentra entre dos grupos
carbón y los los protones son más ácidos
por lo tanto será más fácil de protón ar
este carbono alfa ya que la presencia de
los grupos carbón y lo nos ayudan a
estabilizar por resonancia estos
protones son más ácidos que los protones
de la acetona entonces la base tomará
uno de estos protones dejando los
electrones dibujemos lo que se forma
hemos formado el año en olate y tenemos
un par de electrones libres en este
carbono lo que le da una carga formal
negativa estos electrones en rosa
formaron nuestro carbón jon no dibujaré
la estructura de resonancia es decir el
oxi a nyon porque sólo nos interesa el
producto y ahora que ya tenemos nuestro
año en o latón núcleo físico atacara a
nuestra seton sabemos que este oxígeno
es parcialmente negativo y este carbono
es parcialmente positivo así que nuestro
núcleo filo atacará al electro filo
estos electrones atacarán justo aquí
empujando estos electrones hacia el
oxígeno
si dibujamos el intermediario tenemos
nuestro anillo y formaremos un alc óxido
pero no dibujaré los pares de electrones
libres en el oxígeno porque ahora nos
interesa más la formación de este enlace
dibujemos el resto de la molécula aquí
tenemos nuestros carbón y los
y estos carbonos sigamos a los
electrones estos electrones en rosa
formaron este enlace carbono carbono y
formamos una cox ido pero para ahorrar
tiempo sabemos que al protón ar formamos
nuestro haldol este es nuestro haldol
como intermediario ahora aún tenemos un
protón alfa en este carbono alfa
así que una molécula de óxido entra
y funcionará como una base tomara el
protón y estos electrones se moverán
hacia acá para formar un doble enlace y
finalmente podemos pensar en el
hidróxido como grupo saliente dibujemos
nuestro producto aquí tenemos nuestro
anillo y ahora tenemos un doble enlace
un carbón y lo otro carbón y lo un
oxígeno y un grupo estilo entonces estos
electrones en azul se movieron para
formar este doble enlace y ya teníamos
este enlace carbono carbono así que
tenemos un producto conjugado estable
sólo pensamos en dibujar el producto
para una reacción como si estuviéramos
en un examen espero que esto les ayude